Tamara Alteresco va décoder tout
ça pour nous.
Bonsoir Tamara.
- Bonsoir Patrice. Je vais
essayer.
- Quand il dit : "Je ne veux pas
détruire l'Ukraine".
Est-ce que c'est une tentative
pour baisser le ton un peu.
- Je ne pense pas. Je pense que
ça s'inscrit dans ce discours
qu'il donne, qu'il vend aux
Russes, et aussi à son public.
Il est au Kazakhstan, donc,
avec ses homologues de
l'Asie centrale, Kazakhstan,
Kirghizistan, Ouzbékistan. Donc,
des alliés encore de Vladimir
Poutine, surtout économiques. Et
donc, ça s'inscrit dans ce
discours que la Russie n'est en
mode attaque, elle est en mode
défensive. Rappelez-vous,
on présente encore cette guerre,
ce conflit comme une opération
spéciale nécessaire pour
protéger les intérêts de la
Russie. Donc, le fait d'entendre
Vladimir Poutine aujourd'hui
dire très clairement :
"Notre but n'est pas de la
détruire", c'est dans sa
logique, et vous allez
l'entendre dans l'extraitextrait
qu'on va vous présenter.
C'est qu'il est en mode
défensive et c'étaient ses
attaques multiples vraiment
inégalées depuis la guerre
sur les grandes villes d'Ukraine
cette semaine, c'était en
réponse directe à cette attaque
du pont de la Crimée, qui est un
symbole hyper important
pour la puissance russe.
On peut écouter Vladimir
Poutine, un extrait de sa
conférence de presse.
- Intéressant parce qu'ile qu'il
redit... il dit : "Vous m'avez
provoqué, là, avec le pont de la
Crimée".
- Il prévient : "Pour l'instant,
il n'y aautres
attaques violentes comme ça".
Mais pour la suite,
on ne le sait pas. Autrement
dit: "Si vous osez encore nous
, bien, on va répondre
et on n'hésitera pas de le
faire".
- Bon. Il a dit par ailleurs
dans ce point de presse, il adie
ne sera pas élargie.
On a les hommes qu'il faut."
Or, ça ne correspond pas
tout à fait, disons-le,
à la réalité.
- Non. D'abord, il le dit au
Kazakhstan où il y a, écoutez ça
Patrice, plus de 200 000 hommes
russes q exilés en
moins d'un mois. Donc là aussi,
il y avait un public important.
Et donc, ce qu'il a dit
aujourd'hui Vladimir Poutine,
e la Russie, l'armée
russe avait recruté jusqu'à
maintenant depuis un mois
220 000 hommes. Donc, il en
manque à peu près 80 000et que s
de recrutement, de cette
mobilisation qui est partielle,
seront terminés d'ici deux
semaines. Mais regardez les
vidéos qu'on vous a préparées.
Ça, c'est un échantillon
de ce qu'on retrouve
sur les médias socplusieurs com.
Aujourd'hui, des jeunes hommes,
et ça c'est à Moscou là,
en plein centre-ville, qu'on
attend à l'extérieur ou en bas
de leur appartement, qu'on
attend à la sortie du métro,
et qu'on recrute même s'ils ne
correspondent pas nécessairement
au profil des gens qu'il faut
recruter. Écoutez un extrait,
je pense qu'on voit
une arrestation.
De toute évidence, des gens qun
n'a pas tout le contexte, mais
ces scènes-là, Patrice, se
répètent de ville en ville aumùe
de certaines autorités, c'est le
chaos cette mobilisation.
Et non seulement, la pratique
de mobiliser les hommes
et les erreurs flagrantes
qui ont été faites parce qu'on
recrute des gens qui n'ont pas
le profil des mobilisés,
mais aussi avec l'équipement
et ce qu'on leur donne
pour aller au front.
Il y a des témoignages
qui nous arrivent
de certaines lignes de front
où les soldats témoignent
à la caméra ouvertement :
"On manque de bouffe,
on manque d'équipement,
on a aucun ordre, on a eu deux
semaines d'entraînement".
Plusieurs recrutés, qui sont
arrivés il n'y a même pas une
semaine au front, sont morts,
photos à l'appui. Donc ça,
c'est très difficile
pour Vladimir Poutine cette
question de mobilisation.
Il avait intérêt aujourd'hui,
du moins à signaler
que ça va prendre fin.
Mais est-ce que c'est vrai?
Le temps nous le dira.
- Et rapidement en terminant,
je disais est-ce que
c'est un signe d'apaisement?
Pas vraiment, parce qu'il répète
que ce conflit pourrait
dégénérer en catastrophe
mondiale.
- Oui. Mais ça, ileeeeeeeeee
attention. Il répondait
spécifiquement à l'OTAN.
L'OTAN et plusieurs alliés de
l'Ukrainont
dit : "Si la Russie..."
Parce que ça, c'est une
des grandes craintes;ussie a res
à des armes tactiques,
donc oui des armes nucléaires,
mais peut-être plus petites,
c'est quand même la ligne rouge,
les réactions de l'OTAN vont
être sévères et là on ne parle
pas de sanctions, mais d'une
réponse physique."
Alors, la réponse
de Vladimir Poutine c'est :
"Réfléchissez bien" - et ça, ça
s'adresse à l'OTAN - "s'il y a
un contact direct entre les
forces de l'OTAN et l'armée
russe" - et ça c'est la crainte
depuis le tout début, Patrice -
"on se dirige vers un conflit
qui serait potentiellement
catastrophique pour la planète."
On n'en est pas là et je vous
dirais même que les observateurs
et les renseignements américains
et européens ne voient pas en ce
moment... En tout cas,
ils voient une menace
d'une crise nucléaire
assez faible pour le moment.
- On va espérer que ça reste
comme ça. Tamara Altéresco,
merci beaucoup. Au revoir.